researcher Dan selected one airline  ticket to Hawaii along with several  blank tickets for experimentation before  beginning the test he made this note  this is not duplication for personal  gain it's merely a work field trip for  the broke he placed all the tickets  inside turned the machine to the setting  very fine and weighted this was the  output produced several small economy  airline tickets for researcher Darby  when researcher Dan attempted retrieval  they folded into paper airplanes  reminiscent to c-130s and attempted to  escape containment four were captured by  staff two were shot by on-site weapons  namely the h2o9000 and one escaped  retrieval by entering the air vents and  has presumably escaped aloha